- If you're on this side of the room,
in the kind of front half of it,
what would you like a rap about?
- [Audience Member] Taliban.
- The Taliban?
Okay, wow, great, straight up.
Yeah, can you put the lights on?
Just wanna check he's not
got a long black beard.
(audience laughing)
Great, Taliban.
Taliban's a more acceptable
thing to shout out in a venue.
I had a couple of people a few years ago
who would shout "ISIS!"
and you're like fuck run!
(audience laughing)
The Taliban.
What about the Taliban in particular?
- [Audience Member] What about them?
- Yeah.
- [Audience Member] I'm an ex-soldier.
- You're an ex-soldier?
So have you served over there?
- [Audience Member] Yeah.
- Holy shit it's gonna get dark,
if I carry on asking him questions, so.
(audience laughing)
Okay cool, cool.
So Taliban, lovely.
Guys over here,
kind of front on this side,
what do you want a rap about?
- [Audience Member] The solar system.
- The solar system?
Pick an aspect of the solar
system that isn't a planet.
- [Audience Member] The solar system
and the possibility of life on Enceladus.
(audience laughing)
- Mate, that's a five-star review.
Smashed it, mate, yeah.
(audience laughing)
That's just what you were about to say.
The possibility of life on Celadus?
- [Audience Member] Enceladus.
- Enceladus.
So that is presumably a moon?
- [Audience Member] Yes.
- Of which planet?
- [Audience Member] Well
now it gets awkward,
so I want to say Saturn
but I may be wrong.
- Okay no, that's all right.
Does anyone else?
No one else fucking knows!
(audience laughing)
Oh, you I'll find out on Sun-
- [Audience Member] You'll
find out eventually.
Yeah, no, that's good.
On Sunday I'm staying with my friend
whose an astrophysicist so.
- It's a nice planet,
there's gas plumes has never been said.
(audience laughing)
Okay, the solar system
and the possibility of life on Enceladus.
Great!
Which we don't know where it is,
but it is a moon somewhere.
The Taliban let's come
to the back of that side.
What would you like a rap about?
- [Audience Member]
Just after the Taliban.
- Oh yeah, no.
That's after the Taliban one, yeah.
- [Audience Member] You
know the clip of them
on the dodgems.
- The clip of them on the dodgems?
Yes.
- [Audience Member] Just
to lighten the mood.
- Just to lighten the mood.
So the Talibans on dodgems?
Great. (laughing)
(audience laughing)
Cause that was the one that like
someone tweeted that at like Thorpe Park
or something and they replied to it
being like we're so glad
people are having fun
or something it was great.
Great, Taliban on the dodgems.
Well we're still on this
side for a suggestion.
- [Audience Member] (indistinct)
- What?
- [Audience Member] Goose fare dodgems.
- Goose fare dodgems?
Oh, cool.
Thank you for giving me some local color.
(audience laughing)
Can we just check?
You don't have any fucking
fighting Mujahideen
as well, right?
(audience laughing)
- [Audience Member] I just like dodgems.
- You just like dodgems.
Good out of the two.
That's the one to choose isn't it.
(audience laughing)
You know, "I like bumping
into other people."
Not "I will lay down my life
for the one true lord Allah,
peace be upon him, his
messenger and prophet Mohammed."
Right so we're still on two suggestions
and the show is almost running over.
So what you want a rap about over here?
- [Audience Member] Mushroom rim knob!
- Mushroom rim knob?
(audience laughing)
Yeah, let me just ask what you did say.
Cause that's definitely not
what you said, mushroom what?
- [Audience Member] Rim knob.
- Oh, it is!
(audience laughing)
Okay so I know what the
word that sounds like,
what you said is,
but I don't think that is what you said.
What is?
- [Audience Member] Mushroom rim knob
is a handle for a kitchen cabinet.
- A mushroom rim knob
Oh, it's because you were
saying mushroom rim knob.
Not mushroom rim knob.
Yes.
Emphasis is important, right?
You've got to emphasize
your words properly.
A mushroom rim knob.
Fucking Nottingham what's with you?
Okay, lovely people on this side.
Let's get our fourth suggestion.
Yes is that a hand up yeah?
- [Audience Member] Rip
the shit out of snowflakes.
- Rip the shit out of snowflakes.
Okay. (laughs)
- [Audience Member]
Snowflakes like get it on.
- Okay snowflakes like get it on.
I'm not sure you've
come to the right show.
(audience laughs)
I mean, yeah it's a great suggestion.
Let me just tell you the penultimate song
of this is a hip hop song
without any misogyny whatsoever.
And it seems I've misjudged
my audience completely.
(audience laughing)
Okay, so snowflakes and
one final suggestion.
This can come from anywhere.
- [Audience Member] Donkey jacket.
- Donkey jacket?
Yes, not donkey comma jacket?
What is a donkey jacket?
Is it some type of hesher?
[Audience Member] It's a big
black jacket that dustbin men
used to wear.
- A big black coat that
dustbin men used to wear.
What do we call them now?
Bin collectors, I guess.
Dustbin men used to wear,
it was fashionable in the eighties.
A donkey jacket.
Is it like a kind of
Neo in the matrix thing.
That person said yeah.
That person said no.
Deciding vote.
No, that's a trench coat.
So what's the difference
between a donkey jacket
and a trench coat?
It's shorter.
- [Audience Member] More donkeys.
- More donkeys.
(audience laughing)
I don't know if you a
historian of World War One.
There were quite a few
donkeys in the trenches,
but I wasn't a good
joke at all, but still.
(horn blasts loudly)
(audience laughs)
Okay, cool.
So the Taliban on the dodgems,
a donkey jacket,
mushroom rim knob,
snowflakes rip the out of them
and the possibility of life on N
What was it called?
- [Audience Member] Enceladus.
- Enceladus.
Yes, great.
Okay, which beat if these
is going to be good for that one.
Okay, let me just try it.
Okay, no I've got four beats
and their different moods.
(upbeat music)
Okay yeah this actually,
yeah I think we have got
it straight away. (laughs)
Cool, I'm very excited.
♪ So many clips online ♪
♪ And I urge you to watch them ♪
♪ Big black beard and
they ride in the dodgems ♪
♪ Not their now goose fairing ♪
♪ Kabul the Taliban
they spin right round. ♪
♪ Go in one lot to the next ♪
♪ Bump it from the back ♪
♪ Whiplash in the neck ♪
♪ 'Cause they don't respect the war ♪
♪ They'd be winning ♪
♪ All the men there ♪
♪ But you know no women ♪
♪ Not in the cup and not at the fun fair ♪
♪ I saw a Taliban man ♪
♪ Better run clear ♪
♪ You don't want it with his long hair ♪
♪ He's gonna get you out in ♪
♪ What's that fucking place called ♪
♪ It's called Kandahar ♪
♪ That's what I need ♪
♪ Trying to think of upper properties ♪
♪ You can't exceed 20 years over there ♪
♪ I don't understand ♪
♪ By the wood drawing ♪
♪ No dodgems on the sand ♪
♪ Got a have a nice flat linoleum floor ♪
♪ Is the main thing that
they were fighting the war ♪
♪ For your light yoh Taliban. ♪
♪ When you went to the Royal palace, ♪
♪ Did you want the parliament ♪
♪ They just like no ♪
♪ We just want to have a drive ♪
♪ On all of the dodgems ♪
♪ Me oh my ♪
♪ Ever so fun ♪
♪ Electric on the top ♪
♪ And what is this Russian accent ♪
♪ So we stop right there ♪
♪ I'm going over there understand ♪
And look at me an astrophysicistian
♪ I'm checking out the planets ♪
♪ Like some Patrick Moore ♪
♪ This guy and I say it right ♪
♪ My telescope focusing ♪
♪ And I spy with my little eye ♪
♪ Why are we chatting ♪
♪ We don't even know which
planet is Jupiter or Saturn ♪
♪ Jupiter's got a lot of moons ♪
♪ It's kinda hot ♪
♪ But the gaseous blooms ♪
♪ And not the big red spot ♪
♪ That's a storm ♪
♪ Then maybe it'll be
Saturn with the rings ♪
♪ Sad to see another solar system things ♪
♪ You can't resist thinking
about the possibility of life ♪
♪ Over there ♪
♪ Yes my advice would be
to send a little probe, ♪
♪ Little satellite takes
a while to get there ♪
♪ Maybe 10 years if I'm right, ♪
♪ But probably some more ♪
♪ It's much farther
than the asteroid belt ♪
♪ By Mars there ♪
♪ And let me serve this up ♪
♪ I really hope I'm
envisioning correctly ♪
♪ Your donkey toe ♪
♪ Not the little skin off an ass ♪
♪ Or the skin of a mule ♪
♪ The skin of a donkey
outside the school ♪
♪ Or the bin men up in the 8:00 AM ♪
♪ In the eighties popular
with dustbin men ♪
♪ They'd just be rocking off ♪
♪ No high beers ♪
♪ They've got fashionable clothes ♪
♪ They like this walking around ♪
♪ Maybe it's war approved ♪
♪ You need it for all the muck ♪
♪ That we refuse it ♪
♪ From the recycling ♪
♪ Didn't have that 30 years ago ♪
♪ Technically it's 40 ♪
♪ Jesus Christ I'm trying to go ♪
♪ Bonkers with my head ♪
♪ Snowflakes yeah fucking
wish they were dead ♪
♪ I'm not saying this guy
doesn't like the winter weather ♪
♪ He's like all the fucking kids ♪
♪ Better pull himself together ♪
♪ Back in my day ♪
♪ We said rude words ♪
♪ But now they be like oh ♪
♪ It hurts us ♪
♪ We don't like it ♪
♪ We feel so sad ♪
♪ Oh I'm so depressed ♪
♪ My life is so bad ♪
♪ But the fact is depression
wasn't diagnosed ♪
♪ In the past bin men
wore the black clothes ♪
♪ 'Cause they thought
people didn't give a toss ♪
♪ That's a pun ♪
♪ Bin men black clothes look like goths ♪
♪ And then we move on ♪
♪ Got people online ♪
♪ Sending all this abuse ♪
♪ You're like I don't mind ♪
♪ But let me say this ♪
♪ They're not prudes ♪
♪ I'm just saying it's easy ♪
♪ Europe white dude ♪
♪ Let me all the privilege ♪
♪ And all the other kids
they don't got any ♪
♪ They getting upset ♪
♪ They wish they did ♪
♪ Have something that
would deal with the job ♪
♪ Solution that I've got ♪
♪ That's a mushroom rim knob ♪
♪ I'm going there ♪
♪ Out to Wicks ♪
♪ I'm like so many
handles for me to pick ♪
♪ I'm walking round here ♪
♪ I don't like this angle ♪
♪ And this one too small for the handle ♪
♪ I need one with a wide circumference ♪
♪ A guy walks up and says
we should become friends ♪
♪ I say what's your name ♪
♪ He says Jim ♪
♪ Let me give you a little
knob with a rim man ♪
♪ I'm like whoa ♪
♪ I can't assume I consume him greatly ♪
♪ But there's not much room ♪
♪ And so you know off we prove ♪
♪ We running over there ♪
♪ Get the little kitchen lube ♪
♪ What the heck does that mean ♪
♪ I'm bugging Aina Lee ♪
♪ I'm picking out the rock ♪
♪ And it's such a shame to see ♪
♪ But I managed to ease him in ♪
♪ I start with this ♪
♪ It's called pegging ♪
♪ There you go ♪
♪ Snowflakes for the kids yeah ♪
(audience claps)
(horn blasts loudly)